der nächste Tagesordnungspunkt ist ein
Antrag der Fraktion der cdu/csu
energiepolitische Perspektive für Bürger
und Unternehmen so ist es überschrieben
es geht darum Bürgern und Unternehmen
eine
Perspektive zu geben für die kommenden
Monate in Sachen
Preissteigerungen bei Strom Gas aber
auch bei anderen Verbraucherpreisen die
Preise sollen unter Kontrolle gebracht
werden eine Insolvenzwelle soll
verhindert werden so ist das Ansehen der
Unionsfraktion und deswegen ist sie auch
ganz unzufrieden mit dem
Entlastungspaket 3 mehr dazu von Mario
Czaja aus der Unionsfraktion
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin meine sehr
geehrten Damen und Herren lieber
Bundeswirtschaftsminister es ist glaube
ich die
vierte Debatte in dieser Woche die wir
zum Thema Energiekrise führen
es ist ja auch der einzige konstruktive
und intensive Antrag der heute im
Parlament in dieser Woche vorhanden ist
und die Lage
die Lage ist ausgesprochen kritisch
viele
viele Prominente Fälle
sie brauchen jetzt nicht dazwischen
rufen sondern schauen sich einfach die
Fälle an die wir derzeitig im Land haben
dann werden Sie sehen dass die Lage
dramatisch ist und sie auf diese Lage
nicht reagieren derzeit ist
toilettenpapierhersteller Hakle hat
wegen hohe Energie und Materialkosten
Insolvenz angemeldet
Metallgießerei mit drei Standorten 160
Mitarbeitern in Brandenburg wegen fast
dreifach gestiegener Stromkosten
Insolvenz angemeldet Bäckerei jüngsten
Ostfriesland 99 Jahre da nächstes
jahrhundertjähriges Jubiläum so stark
steigende Energiekosten dass sie vor der
Insolvenz stehen jedes dritte
Unternehmen im industriellen Mittelstand
sieht den gestiegenen Energie- und
Rohstoffpreisen so kritisch gegenüber
dass die eigene Existenz in Frage steht
fast jedes zehnte Unternehmen in
Deutschland hat bereits die Produktion
gedrosselt oder ganz eingestellt viele
Unternehmen haben Angst dass sie
Unternehmen bei draufgeht dass ihr
Lebenswerk in Frage gestellt wird dass
es keine Jobs mehr gibt dass die
Familien in Gefahr sind das ist eine
dramatische Situation und auf diese
Situation reagiert diese Bundesregierung
in keiner anständigen Art und Weise
und
jetzt werden wir höchstwahrscheinlich
höchstwahrscheinlich von einzelnen
wieder die Aussagen bekommen ja die
Ursachen und 16 Jahre dieser Evergreen
den wir hier immer und immer wieder
hören
die Wahrheit ist eben durch die Wahrheit
ist eben nur die Ursache für die
jetzigen Probleme sind die letzten 16
Wochen nicht die letzten 16 Jahre
sie hätte die Bundesregierung hätte die
Bundesregierung Ideologie frei die Dinge
angepackt die wir anpacken wollten
nämlich das Angebot zu erhöhen dann
werden die Probleme heute nicht so groß
wie sie sind hätte die Bundesregierung
den energiepreisdeckel gemacht die wir
Ihnen vorgeschlagen haben vorher schon
vor 16 Wochen wer die Lage heute nicht
so dramatisch hätte man die wirklich
Betroffenen entlastet und nicht mit der
Gießkanne an allen Ecken und Endungen
Veränderungen herbeizuführen dann würden
die Rentner auch jetzt zum ersten
zehnten ihre 300 Euro energiegeld
bekommen das ist aber nicht der Fall
unsere Vorschläge lagen auf dem Tisch
und
und es liegt doch auf der Hand dass sie
jetzt so dazwischen rufen weil aus ihren
eigenen Reihen weil aus ihren eigenen
Reihen die genau die gleichen Vorschläge
immer wieder kommen nun ich hier im
Parlament
spd-arbeitnehmerflüge fordert
gaspreisdeckel staatlichen
gaspreisdeckel soll stattfinden liest
man auch übrigens in weiten Teilen der
SPD wir hören das Christian Lindner sagt
dass wir beim Angebot die Kernkraftwerke
aufstocken müssen und dass wir bei den
drei Kernkraftwerken bleiben müssen wir
hören von Herrn Habeck dass er sagt bei
der Biomasse sollten wir endlich was tun
die niedersächsischen Bauern sagen dass
wenn Sie Ihre bestehenden Biogasanlagen
vollständig ausnutzen könnten die jetzt
schon bestehenden können Sie fünf
Prozent des russischen Gases ersetzen
sie macht können es aber nicht machen
weil die rechtlichen Rahmenbedingungen
von ihnen derzeitig dafür nicht
geschaffen werden
und es fällt wirklich schwer aber
unsererseits gilt weiterhin die
ausgestreckte Hand wir erreichten die
Hand für eine konstruktive
Zusammenarbeit und für die Lösung dieser
Probleme unsere Vorschläge liegen seit
Wochen seit Tag und Wochen auf dem Tisch
und wir sagen klar alles für eine
sichere Energieversorgung mobilisieren
wenn es wenn das Angebot knapp ist
steigt der Preis einfache Regel erstes
Semester Habeck bei
Betriebswirtschaftslehre Kernkraftwerke
weiterlaufen lassen biogasdeckel wieder
anheben auch die Änderungen im
Baugesetzbuch ist dafür notwendig um das
bei der biogasse hinzu Biomasse
hinzubekommen deswegen der erste Punkt
bleibt das Angebot
das zweite Thema ist weiterhin die
Bürger zu entlasten und für eine
bezahlbare Grundversorgung zu sorgen
dafür haben wir den preisdeckel
vorgeschlagen und zwar auf einem Niveau
von 75% haben wir ihn diskutiert um auch
die Anreize dahingehend zu haben zu
sparen und gleichzeitig eben auch
Sicherheit für alle Einkommen zu
gewährleisten und das dritte ist die
Unternehmen anständig zu unterstützen
das tun sie nicht stand siebter Neunter
haben 586 Unternehmen
3208 Anträge gestellt um aus ihrem Fond
Mittel zu bekommen
3.200 und 8 Anträge davon sind 24 24
sind davon positiv beschieden worden das
ist lächerlich und keine Unterstützung
sowie der Mittelstand überhaupt
sie haben ja am Beginn dieser Woche ein
fußballbild bedient um die Debatte zu
beschreiben
ich bin manchmal im Stadion
und wenn ich da so auf die Mannschaft
runter schaue dann sind die Fans relativ
leidensfähig die Murren nicht immer
aber wenn sie merken dass die Mannschaft
da unten nur gegeneinander agiert und
nicht gemeinsam aufs Tor geht und nicht
die wesentlichen Dinge im Auge hat und
das ist das was wir derzeitig bei der
Bundesregierung erleben dann müssen Sie
sich nicht wundern dass es dafür kein
Applaus mehr gibt sondern dass es dafür
erhebliche Kritik gibt sie sind mit
dafür verantwortlich dass wir ein
solches Chaos und ein solches
gegeneinander in dieser Regierung
erleben wir haben den Gegenvorschlag auf
den Tisch gelegt folgt sie diesen
Mario Czaja für die cdu/csu-fraktion er
ist ja auch Generalsekretär der CDU und
ich würde jetzt mal interessieren welche
Stadion er gemeint hat denn die
Beschreibung die er abgeliefert hat von
der Mannschaft die ja da vermeintlich
sieht kann auf Union Berlin ja
eigentlich gar nicht so richtig passen
passiv sind die nun wirklich nicht
Timon gremmels ist der nächste Redner
und er kommt aus der SPD-Fraktion
[Applaus]
frau Präsidentin meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren ich glaube jeder von
uns kann Beispiele aus seinen Wahlkreis
nennen wie die Situation vor Ort ist ich
war in den letzten Wochen unter anderem
bei einem Müller einer der 150 Malereien
die noch selber Mehl malen und nicht
Industriekonzern untergeordnet sind der
hat mir gesagt noch zahlt er 5 Cent
Strompreis die Kilowattstunde sein
Mühlgraben ist ausgetrocknet und das
Angebot für den nächsten ersten weil da
läuft seinen Strompreis ist ein
Stromvertrag aus sind 70 Cent pro
Kilowattstunde das schafft er nicht und
er sagt dann kann er eben hier kein Mehl
mehr malen und was das dann in Folge für
Auswirkungen hätte auch auf die
Nahrungsmittelpreise auch die
Nahrungsmittel Verfügbarkeit das kann
sich jeder vorstellen und ich hatte auch
das Gespräch mit einer Bäckerei in
meinem Wahlkreis die vor einem Jahr in
einen neuen Ofen investiert haben und
gesagt haben jetzt super das wird jetzt
alles effizienter werden wie das noch
und jetzt aber auch vor den großen
Problemen der steigenden Energiepreise
stehen diese Menschen wenden sich an uns
und die Menschen sagen wir brauchen
Unterstützung und ich kann sagen ja
diese Koalition liefert diese Koalition
handelt wir unterstützen hier gilt das
Wort unseres Kanzlers oder Scholz keiner
wird alleine gelassen you never walk
alone meine sehr verehrten Damen und
Herren und ganz konkret ist das was ihr
einfach mal auch von dieser
Bundesregierung auf den Weg gebracht
worden ist für die große
exportorientierte Industrie nämlich das
kostendämpfungsprogramm Energiekosten
dämpfungsprogramm jetzt auch angekündigt
dass das um eine mittelstandsschiene für
Kleid und mittlere Unternehmen erweitert
werden soll das ist genau das richtige
Signal dass es jetzt auch Programme gibt
die für den Mittelstand die für das
Handwerk orientiert sind und deswegen
ist es gut dass das angekündigte wurde
es ist gut dass das auch wenn ich den
Minister richtig verstanden habe
rückwirkend erfolgen soll per
Abschlagszahlung erfolgen soll als
Zuschuss erfolgen soll das hilft konkret
das ist konkretes Handeln meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren
was mir dann allerdings schon schwerer
fällt nachzuvollziehen ist wenn ich dann
höre dass es jetzt administrative
Probleme gibt weil die Schnittstellen
nicht so ganz da sind weil diese
Computerprogramme neu programmiert
werden soll weil es Probleme gibt
welches Instrument der Auszahlung man
wählen soll ich habe so ein bisschen das
Gefühl gehabt ich käme mir vor wie vor
zwei Jahren in der corona-pandemie weil
der all diese Probleme hatten ich glaube
wir müssen dringend mal gucken dass wir
Strukturen schaffen die auch nachhaltig
wirken und mein Appell auch an die Union
die das heute hier zum Thema macht sie
sollten auch mal gucken was in ihren
eigenen Ländern ist wenn ich höre dass
sich der einige Länder weigern sozusagen
bei der Frage der Auszahlung ihre
Infrastruktur zur Verfügung zu stellen
weil die Länder noch in der Abwicklung
der corona-programme beschäftigt sind
den Schlussabrechnung kann das auch
nicht sein wir sind in einer Situation
einer nationalen größten Herausforderung
seit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg hier darf es
nicht sein dass Bund und Länder
gegeneinander Politik betreiben sondern
hier müssen wir gemeinsam dafür sorgen
dass die Zahlungen schnell ausgeführt
werden meine Damen und Herren und
erwarten wir dass die Länder vor ihrem
Beitrag leisten und dass sie ihre
Möglichkeiten die bei der
corona-pandemie
konstruktiv zur Verfügung stellen meine
sehr verehrten Damen und Herren deswegen
ist es gut dass wir hier an dieser
Stelle handeln und wir machen ja noch
mehr die großartige Erfindung des
Kurzarbeitergeldes die damals Olaf
Scholz als Arbeits- und Sozialminister
auf den Weg gebracht hat die uns schon
geholfen hat in der corona-pandemie auch
die wird jetzt weiter genutzt auch das
ist etwas was Menschen in einer
schwierigen Situation Sicherheit gibt
und das ist auch gut meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren und wir haben
noch was gemacht wir haben jetzt eine
energiepreisbremse auf den Weg gebracht
und wo wir sagen die zufallsgewinne die
jetzt entstehen die müssen abgeschöpft
werden es ist eine Frage der Solidarität
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
und damit ist auch die rechte Seite die
im Hause versteht ist eine Frage des
Patriotismus ist es jetzt nicht sein
kann dass die unter Firmen jetzt schon
wieder gucken dass sie Auswege und
Schlupflöcher suchen um das nicht zahlen
zu müssen mein Appell heute ist hier an
dieser Stelle auch die Unternehmen auch
die Industrie die jetzt dort auch die
Energiewirtschaft die an dieser Stelle
richtige Gewinne macht muss sich
solidarisch muss sich patriotisch
Verhalten und nicht Auswege suchen
sondern das Geld zahlen was wir brauchen
um die Menschen zu entlasten meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren das muss an
dieser Stelle auch mal deutlich gesagt
werden das muss deutlich gesagt werden
ja und wir müssen auch weitere Dinge tun
schneller als wir es vorhatten das
mag-design das strohmarktdesign zu
überarbeiten aber meine Damen und Herren
das ist eine Operation am offenen Herzen
das kann man nicht von heute auf morgen
bei ebenso schnell durchpeitschen das
braucht das ist europäisch verletzt wenn
wir hier Fehler machen dann droht eine
große Katastrophe und ich will an dieser
Stelle sagen deswegen müssen wir hier
gemein
ja ich höre ja immer ihre klugen
Vorschläge hier vorne es ist aber in der
Tat so dass wir da ganz gut zusammen
rangehen müssen und Herrscher wenn Sie
hier eben gerade sagen was man alles
hätte tun müssen ich sage Ihnen jetzt
mal zwei Dinge die hätte getan werden
müssen wenn Herr Seehofer und dann
später Herr Söder als Ministerpräsident
von Bayern nicht sozusagen den südlichen
verhindert hätten gegen jede Leitung
gekämpft hätten wenn sie nicht 10h
eingeführt hätten dann wären wir heute
deutlich weiter dann hätte insbesondere
Bayern diese Probleme nicht vor dem wir
heute stehen deswegen gucken Sie sich
nicht aus der Verantwortung ich mache
mir jetzt nicht so leicht und rekoriere
auf die 16 Jahre das ja das ist jetzt ja
ein Jahr her man sollte nein das mache
ich nicht aber Herr Söder ist heute noch
in der Verantwortung deswegen sage ich
heute muss er liefern auch heute muss er
endlich 10A komplett abschaffen auch
jetzt muss er sein Widerstand gegen
Stromtrassen aufgeben das hat nichts für
die letzten Jahren zu tun die letzten 16
Jahre das hat mit der Gegenwart zu tun
jetzt muss gehandelt werden meine sehr
verehrten Damen und Herren
und ich sage ihnen war ja eine spannende
Rede sie machen hier in der in der
Kernzeit so eine Debatte auf und gehen
gar nicht darauf ein dass wir heute
morgen um sieben eine Anhörung hatten im
energieausschuss zum ensig 3.0
energiesicherungsgesetz 3.0 wo wir
intensiv diskutieren wie wir jetzt
kurzfristig und schnell die Potenziale
heben das ist nein nicht seit nein wir
gucken beim zum Beispiel beim N6 3.0
Netze da gibt es effizienzmodule da gibt
es sehr effizienzmöglichkeiten bei der
Windkraft beim Gas bei der Photovoltaik
da werden wir der nächsten Woche hier
etwas auf den Weg bringen was sofort ja
nächste Woche ist die dritte Lesung was
ganz schnell hilft meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren und nochmals wenn Sie
jetzt hier reinschreien das Versagen
liegt doch bei ihnen sie haben die
letzten sie haben doch immer gegen
Windkraft gekämpft und sie kämpfen doch
auch heute noch gegen Windkraftanlagen
und da gucken wir mal ihre Bilanz an
gucken wir mal ihre Bilanz an da wo sie
mit regieren ich sage Ihnen eins ich war
letzte Woche bei der IHK mittelstandsaus
die waren bei mir in Kassel und die
haben auch über Energiepolitik
diskutiert da ging es gar nicht in
erster Linie und Förderprogramme da ging
es darum dass die Bürokratie das
Genehmigungsverfahren so Engländer
dauern da hat ein Unternehmen gesagt sie
könnten schon heute auf Fotovoltaik
setzen wenn dort die Verfahren länger
gedauert werden und ich sage eins gleich
bei Windkraft da wo sie regieren Hessen
38,2 Monate Planungszeit für ein
Windkraftanlage das muss geändert werden
wir müssen schneller werden müssen
schneller erneuerbare Energien aufs
Tableau bringen das ist die Antwort aus
der Krise das hilft auch den
Bäckermeister vor Ort erneuerbare
Energien sind auf lange Sicht der
kostensenker in diesem Sinne alles Gute
und Glück auf
so und dann haben wir die erwarteten
Emotionen in dieser Debatte in der es um
einen Antrag der cdu/csu-fraktion geht
die energiepolitische Perspektiven für
Bürgerinnen und Unternehmen fordert
Enrico coming ist jetzt am Pult für die
afd-fraktion Herr Kollegen die
wirtschaftliche Lage der Unternehmen
spezielle Mittelschule mittelständischen
Unternehmen als dramatisch zu bezeichnen
ist aus meiner Sicht schon fast ein
Euphemismus in meiner Heimatstadt
Neubrandenburg schließen sich
verzweifelte Unternehmer zusammen und
sie gehen auf die Straße der erste
unternehmeraufstand letzter Woche
folgten fast 3000 Menschen und ich sage
Ihnen das ist erst der Anfang die
Menschen die Unternehmer sie wehren sich
gegen eine Politik der Ideologen der
ökologieisten unter ahnungslosen und das
ist gut so meine Damen und Herren
liebe Kollegen von der Union in einem
gebe ich Ihnen und Ihrem Antrag recht
Ursache für die flächendeckende
Existenzbedrohung sind natürlich keine
unternehmerischen Entscheidung aber sehr
wohl politische politische
Entscheidungen Herr Czaja die sie und
sie meine Damen und Herren Kollegen von
der Union allen voran zu vertreten haben
die heute explodierenden Energiepreise
sind doch nur die seismischen
Erschütterungen die die Welle zum
Zunahme nie machen ihre Bundeskanzlerin
Merkel und ihr Wirtschaftsminister
Altmaier haben dieses Land energetisch
lautverband an die Wand gefahren
natürlich natürlich ist es auch der
gastkrieg auch der gastkrieg ist schuld
aber auch wessen Mist ist der denn
bitteschön gewachsen wenn sie enttrauter
Eintracht mit der ampelregierung den
größten Rohstofflieferanten der Welt
sanktionieren das kann man ja machen
dann müssen sie aber mit den
entsprechenden Reaktionen rechnen sie
haben mit dem Schicksal der deutschen
gepokert ohne Blatt und offen ein
wirklich mieser blass
und jetzt meine Damen und Herren jetzt
ist Holland oder besser Deutschland in
Not und sie kommen mit einem Antrag
voller
planwirtschaftlicher Lösungen staatlich
festgelegte Preise für staatlichung von
gasspeichern es ist im Grunde ein
Gruselkabinett Anforderungen die sie
hier stellen liebe Kollegen von der
Union ich verstehe ihren Ansatz den Sie
mit diesem Antrag verfolgen aber dieses
ausschließliche Herumdoktern an
Symptomen verspricht doch keine
energiepolitische Perspektive das
erreichen Sie nur durch Freiheit durch
Marktwirtschaft
Staatswirtschaft war noch nie die Lösung
Staatswirtschaft ist immer das Problem
verlassen sie verlassen sie den Weg
dieser entsetzlichen
sozialökologischen Transformationen den
Weg zu einer staatlich kontrollierten
Kreislaufwirtschaft denn er führt zu den
ins Industrialisierung zu Massenarmut
und zu Unfreiheit
sie drücken sich mit ihrem Antrag um das
eigentliche Problem das ist nämlich die
Energiewende
verabschieden sie sich endlich von
diesem Monstrum nur dann schaffen sie
auch eine wirkliche echte Perspektive
für Bürger und Unternehmen so aber so
aber liebe Union können wir ihrem Antrag
nicht zustimmen dieser Krieg diese
Energiekrise zeigen einmal mehr
Deutschland kann nur als starkes Land
bestehen wenn es eine Zukunft im Konzert
der Nationen haben will und deshalb
meine Damen und Herren gerade da oben
vielleicht auf der Tribüne aber auch
meine Damen und Herren Kollegen der
Union lassen Sie uns gemeinsam diesen
kamikazeflug der Bundesregierung stoppen
demonstrieren Sie mit uns am 8 Oktober
hier in Berlin gegen diese Politik
beenden wir diesen in Energiewende
Irrsinn finden wir zurück zu
Marktwirtschaft und Freiheit nicht nur
die Menschen in unserem Land auch der
Mittelstand wird es Ihnen danken vielen
Dank
[Applaus]
Enrico coming aus der afd-fraktion
spricht von einem Gaskrieg und schafft
es auch in seiner Rede die Ursachen für
die aktuelle Lage komplett auszublenden
nämlich den Angriff Russlands auf die
Ukraine Dieter janitschek ist der
nächste rednerwirtschaftspolitischer
Sprecher der Fraktion Bündnis 90 die
Grünen
sehr geehrte Frau Präsidentin sehr
geehrter Herr schaja die wirtschaftliche
Situation für viele Betriebe ist
besorgniserregend in Deutschland für
manche geht es an die Existenz wir haben
steigende Energiekosten durch den
russischen Angriffskrieg allein die
Ersatzbeschaffung für russisches Gas in
diesem Jahr kostet uns um die 60
Milliarden Euro im nächsten Jahrhundert
Milliarden volkswirtschaftlich sind das
gigantische Verluste wir erleben die
Unterbrechung der internationalen
Lieferketten auch durch Entscheidungen
in China wie nur coburg-politik dort die
Zins wenn sie der Zentralbanken belastet
natürlich auch Unternehmen zum Beispiel
im Bausektor in der Immobilienwirtschaft
dort haben wir einen deutlichen downturn
jetzt auch zu erwarten und auch die in
der Sache berechtigten höheren
Lohnforderungen sind natürlich aufgrund
von Inflationen für viele Unternehmen
erstmal eine Belastung
diese Probleme betreffen aber zurzeit
nicht uns regulär sie betreffen alle
europäischen Länder Glashersteller in
Frankreich Stahlwerke in Spanien
düngemittelfabriken in Polen viele
Branchen stehen vor großen
Herausforderungen und daher brauchen wir
auch europäische Lösungen der
unionsantrag nennt nicht mit einem Wort
Europa und das zeigt wie beschränkt sie
hier wieder agieren das war doch schon
in der Vergangenheit das Problem
wir brauchen eine europäisch abgestimmte
koordinierte Energiepolitik
Frankreich als Beispiel leidet zurzeit
unter den extrem hohen Strompreisen weil
sich dieses Land völlig abhängig gemacht
hat von der Atomkraft und deswegen
mussten wir diesen Sommer diesen Herbst
aushelfen um Frankreich zu stabilisieren
Deutschland hat sich in der
Vergangenheit von Vorgängerregierungen
abhängig gemacht in einer Art und Weise
von russischen Gas was uns heute in
diese Bredouille in diese schwierige
Situation gebracht hat das heißt
undurchdachte Energiepolitik der
Vergangenheit ist eine Folge des
Desasters heute und wir müssen damit
umgehen und das gehört auch zu
Ehrlichkeit hätten sie uns nicht in die
Abhängigkeit von solchen Autokraten
geführt würden wir heute anders dastehen
[Applaus]
nun ist es ja so
wenn sie sagen dass wir mit zu wenig
Dynamik handeln würden
dass es wirklich eine Forderung einer
Feststellung die lachhaft ist es gab
kein Wirtschaftsministerium in den
letzten Jahrzehnten das so dynamisch auf
eine Krise reagiert hat wie dieses
Wirtschaftsministerium und der Robert
Habeck
wir haben bei Regierungsübernahme Lehre
Gasspeicher übernommen jetzt haben wir
volle Gasspeicher in schwierigster Lage
seitdem können wir übrigens auch Preise
wieder drücken weil wir in der Lage sind
dass wir nicht mehr zu jedem Preis
einkaufen müssen wir müssen die
Einkaufspolitik der Europäischen Union
beim Thema Gas bündeln natürlich müssen
wir auch den Unternehmen helfen deswegen
steht jetzt ganz konkret in den
Verhandlungen im Kabinett im Parlament
an dass wir ein
energiekostendämpfungsprogramm für alle
energieintensiven Betriebe auf den Weg
bringen und insbesondere auch die
kleinen und mittelständischen
Unternehmen stützen
wir können aber auch die dysfunktionalen
Energiemärkte die wir vorfinden nicht so
im Bestand lassen in einer solchen
Krisensituation geht es auch darum
zufallsgewinne abzuschöpfen deswegen
setze ich sehr auf die Verhandlung jetzt
im EU-Ministerrat kommende Woche die
werden alles andere als einfach denn man
kann natürlich auch schon
Ausweichbewegungen sehen auf den Märkten
die versuchen sich vor solchen
zufallsgewinnen abschöpfungen sozusagen
zu verstecken aber es ist notwendig dass
die Tatsache dass wir bei der Produktion
von Strom ganz andere Krediten finden
hat bei dem Verkauf dass wir daran gehen
und sagen das gehen wir zurück an die
Kunden an die Unternehmen damit ihr den
Strompreis runter kriegen größte Aufgabe
der Politik ist jetzt die Preise nach
unten zu bringen das haben wir mit einer
Ausweitung des Angebots bei LNG beim
Eingriffen Strommarkt bei dem Hochfahren
der Kohlekraftwerke all das bringen wir
auf den Weg und haben entschlossen
gehandelt in den letzten Wochen
wer entlasten auch die energieintensiven
Unternehmen bereits jetzt über 1,7
Milliarden Euro Energie und Stromsteuer
durch die Verlängerung des
Spitzenausgleichs um ein Jahr die
Anpassung der insolvenzregelung ist in
Planung Unternehmen sollen nicht mehr
ihr Fortbestehen über die nächsten 12
sondern nur noch vier Monate nachweisen
auch das ist jetzt krisenrelevant dass
wir das tun und ganz zum Schluss möchte
ich aber auch das relevanteste eingehen
wir können jetzt abfedern wir können
helfen das tun wir mit der finanziellen
Stärke unseres Staates und ich bin der
Meinung wir sollten eher mehr
finanzielle Stärke nutzen als weniger in
einer solchen Krisensituation aber es
geht jetzt auch ganz darum das Thema
Energieeffizienz Zukunft Investitionen
heute im Handelsblatt ein gutes
edoterial dazu es ist auch eine Chance
in einer solchen Krise verborgen dass
wir uns jetzt wettbewerbsfähig
aufstellen und deswegen ist der Klima-
und
transformationsfondsregierung der auf 35
Milliarden erhöht worden ist ein
relevantes Instrument nach vorne zu
schauen wir müssen uns unabhängig machen
russischer Energie aber wir müssen auch
jetzt die Maß greifen damit wir
wettbewerbsfähig mit erneuerbaren
Energien Energieeffizienz neuen
Geschäftsmodellen und eine bessere
Zukunft schauen ich danke Ihnen
Dieter Janecek war das der
wirtschaftspolitische Sprecher der
Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen und ihm
wird jetzt in dieser Debatte über
energiepolitische Perspektiven für
Bürger und Unternehmen so hat die
Unionsfraktion ihren Antrag
überschrieben Janine Wissler
Parteivorsitzende der linken und
natürlich auch Mitglied der
Linksfraktion
wenn man sich den Antrag der
Unionsfraktion anschaut dann reibt man
sich schon verwundert die Augen was sie
daran so alles fordern preisdecke
staatliche Eingriffe in den Strommarkt
Verstaatlichung von kritischer
Infrastruktur Maßnahmen die sie bis vor
kurzem noch als sozialistisches
Teufelszeug geistet hätten offenbar
merken auch Sie Herr Merz der Markt
regelt es eben nicht
ja die aktuelle Energiekrise ist eine
Folge verfehlter Energiepolitik die
Energiewende wurde verschleppt und
gerade sie von der Union haben vor Ort
oft gegen jedes neue Windrad gekämpft
sehen dann Auges wurde dadurch die
Abhängigkeit von fossilen Energien und
von Energie-
meine Damen und Herren die Inflation
verschärft die Spaltung zwischen oben
und unten und sie stürzt viele Menschen
und viele Unternehmen in Existenz Goethe
und zu Recht gibt es deshalb Proteste
die ja auch erste Wirkung zeigen
immerhin bekommen jetzt auch Rentner und
Studierende Hilfe aber die
Einmalzahlungen verpuffen angesichts der
dauerhaft hohen Preise für Lebensmittel
und Energie und wir schlagen deshalb für
niedrige und mittlere Einkommen ein
monatliches inflationsgeld von
mindestens 125 Euro vor und eine
sofortige und deutliche Erhöhung der
Hartz-IV-Regelsätze das ist dringend
notwendig
aber auch das wird nicht reichen um die
explodierenden Gaspreise auszugleichen
dafür brauchen wir einen gaspreisdeckel
viele Menschen bekommen in diesen Tagen
Briefe von ihren Gasversorgern dass sich
ihre Abschlagszahlungen verdreifacht bis
verzehnfacht haben Familien und Ränder
sollen dreistellige oder gar
vierstellige Beträge zahlen für Gas und
zwar monatlich das kann man durch
direkte Hilfen überhaupt nicht
ausgleichen dafür muss man die
Spekulation bekämpfen in den Strommarkt
eingreifen und einen preisdeckel
einführen meine Damen und Herren Spanien
Portugal Belgien Großbritannien und
andere Länder tun das wo in Frankreich
dürfen die Energiepreise nur um vier
Prozent steigen wir fordern ein
kostengünstiges grundkontingent für
Strom und Gas sowie ein gesetzliches
Verbot von Strom und gassperren damit
niemand in diesem Land im Winter frieren
muss
und hoher verbraucht muss im Gegenzug
deutlich teurer werden mit der gasumlage
wollen sie die Kosten für die graskrise
auf die Verbraucher abwälzen die
zufälligerweise mit gasheizen worauf wie
Mieterinnen und Mieter überhaupt kein
Einfluss haben und Sie haben ja selber
gemerkt dass das Quatsch ist aber den
nächsten Quatsch gleich hinterher
beschlossen nämlich die Senkung der
Mehrwertsteuer für alle gasgründen das
ist zwar teuer gleich aber die
Mehrkosten bei vielen die alte Verträge
haben überhaupt nicht aus die gasumlage
meine Damen und Herren ist Murks sie ist
falsch und deshalb muss sie abgeschafft
werden
es ist richtig
Herr Minister Habeck Gasversorger zu
retten und in die staatliche Hand zu
überführen um einen Kollaps bei der
Versorgung zu verhindern das muss aber
aus Steuermitteln erfolgen und das
sollte auch dauerhaft sein denn
Energieversorgung gehört als Teil der
öffentlichen Daseinsvorsorge in die
öffentliche Hand und unter demokratische
Kontrolle wieder einmal werden Verluste
sozialisiert und Gewinne privatisiert
einige Konzerne machen riesen Gewinne in
dieser Krise und deshalb brauchen wir
eine übergewinnsteuer die haben viele
Länder eingeführt die EU-Kommission
empfiehlt das sogar führen Sie die
endlich ein
meine Damen und Herren Finanzminister
Lindner beklagt dass es einsam um ihn
werde beim Festhalten an der Illusion
die Schuldenbremse im nächsten Jahr noch
einhalten zu können ja es ist nicht
einfach
eigene Weltbild auf die Realität trifft
den Kürzeren zieht und alle es merken
außer einem selbst die Schuldenbremse
muss ausgesetzt werden besser noch
abgeschafft werden wir brauchen
Investitionen in die Energiewende den
Ausbau des ÖPNV wir brauchen
Investitionen in den Klimaschutz das ist
die Verantwortung gegenüber kommenden
Generationen und nicht das Klammern als
ein offensichtlich schädliches Dogma
vielen Dank
vielen Dank Frau Kollegin Wissler
nächster Redner ist der Kollege Reinhard
Huben FDP-Fraktion und da ist er
wirtschaftspolitischer Sprecher
[Applaus]
herr Präsident meine Damen und Herren
eine Vorbemerkung zum Thema Dynamik von
Ministerien
meine erste Veranstaltung als Mitglied
des Deutschen Bundestags 2017 war eine
Debatte über der Reform des postgesetzes
wahrhaftig ein schwerwiegendes Thema
in den letzten vier Jahren ist es dem
letzten Wirtschaftsminister nicht
gelungen ein solches Gesetz auf die
Reihe zu bringen und dich finde es dann
schon starker ja dass sie diesem
Ministerium und diesen Minister
nun fehlende dynamikvorwärts ihr könnt
ja mit den Entscheidungen nicht in
Einklang stehen das ist ja vollkommen in
Ordnung aber wenn ich sehe was dieses
Ministerium neben vielen anderen in der
Krise in unserem Land leisten ist sehr
dynamisch meine Damen und Herren da
brauchen wir uns überhaupt nicht
versteckt
meine Damen und Herren ich bin selbst
Unternehmer mein Unternehmen handelt mit
elektroinstallationsmaterial und ich
habe mal zu Hause geguckt
wie hoch ist denn unser
Energiekostenanteil am Umsatz und der
ist so niedrig dass mein Unternehmen
keine Unterstützung braucht das heißt im
Umkehrschluss natürlich nicht dass es
die Bäckereien gibt das ist die
Ziegelhersteller gibt das ist die
Papierhersteller gibt und so weiter und
so fort diese müssen unterstützt werden
aber wenn die Wirtschaft selbst der
Mittelstand gegenüber der KfW erklärt
zu mindestens 55 Prozent haben wir
natürlich Probleme mit steigenden
Energiekosten aber wir kommen damit klar
dann haben wir doch die Aufgabe Lösungen
zu finden die möglichst zielgenau sind
und da sind wir es ist ja eben
dargestellt worden auch mitten in der
Debatte und ich halte es nicht für klug
ich hatte es nicht für klug wie sie das
tun hier so ein Füllhorn an Lösungen für
unterschiedlichste Gruppierungen
auszuschütten ich frage mal liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der Union
haben Sie eigentlich ihren Antrag mit
den Haushältern abgestimmt
haben sie das abgeschirmt ich finde es
interessant sie eröffnen Möglichkeiten
zum Ausgeben von Geld im sackten
dreistelligen Milliarden
Milliardenbereich und die einzige
konkrete Finanzierung die sie
vorschlagen ist das eeg-konto wo im
Moment schätzungsweise 17-18 Milliarden
Euro liegen also deswegen halte ich den
Antrag an dieser Stelle nicht für sales
und wir müssen natürlich auch meine
Damen und Herren mit einer Illusion
aufhören
und das suggeriert ihr Antrag
wir werden selbst wenn wir diese Gas-
und Kohlekrise überstanden haben der
Weltmarktpreis vom Öl hat sich ja schon
relativ beruhigt wenn wir also diese
Krise überstanden haben eins sicherlich
nicht haben nämlich ein Preisniveau für
Energie wie es vor dem Angriffskrieg
Russlands gegen die Ukraine war deswegen
müssen wir und muss auch die Wirtschaft
selbst erkennen dass bestimmte
Geschäftsmodelle nur dann funktionieren
wenn entsprechend preiswerte
Energieträger eingebaut werden und das
sind natürlich zum großen Teil auch
sogenannte oder alternative Energie
und zum Abschluss meine Damen und Herren
und zum Abschluss für Sie persönlicher
erlauben Sie mir auch eine Bemerkung wir
haben natürlich im Moment kein
Nachfrageproblem sondern ein
angebotsproblem und das gilt
selbstverständlich auch ja aber welche
Lösungen bieten sie denn in ihrem Antrag
was die Angebotsseite angeht da sehe ich
nicht sehr viel meine Damen und Herren
denn selbst die Union ist nicht in der
Lage den Gas Weltmarktpreis hier
festzulegen also das ist doch nur
wirklich nicht wahr und natürlich ändert
sich der Preis wenn das Angebot erhöht
wird deswegen werden ja lng-terminals
gebaut in Deutschland dazu waren sie
außerdem in den letzten Jahren auch
nicht in der Lage mal so als nebenbei
Bemerkung in ihren jeweiligen
Koalitionen und sicherlich ist es
kurzfristig für die nächsten zwei Winter
sinnvoll die Atomkraftwerke die zwei bis
drei die einsatzfähig sind auch länger
laufen zu lassen in dem Sinne vielen
Dank für Ihre aufmerksam
Reinhard Hugen war das
wirtschaftspolitischer Sprecher der
FDP-Fraktion der auch noch mal betont
hat dass nicht alle Unternehmen gleich
betroffen sind von steigenden
Energiepreisen und er hat auch noch mal
betont die Bedeutung erneuerbarer
Energien für die Zukunft Julia Klöckner
ist ein Pult wirtschaftspolitische
Sprecherin der Unionsfraktion
Präsident herrberg liebe
und Kollegen
erlebe dein grünes Wirtschaftswunder das
haben die Grünen plakatiert im
Bundestagswahlkampf
und Robert oder Landtagswahlkampf soll
mir auch recht sein Robert Habeck hat
dieses Wunder dieser Tage dann noch mal
konkretisiert und ich zitiere es wie er
sich dieses grüne Wirtschaftswunder
vorstellt wenn mit dem gasparen alles
gut geht und wir Glück mit dem Wetter
haben dann haben wir eine Chance gut
durch diesen Winter zu kommen aber ich
kann Ihnen sagen in dieser schwierigen
Situation brauchen wir kein
bundesschamanen der da gutes Wetter
hofft sondern wir brauchen einen
Wirtschaftsminister der die richtigen
Entscheidungen in dieser Situation
trifft
und lieber Herr Ruben und auch Herr
Janecek sie sprechen davon was sie alles
Vorhaben und bauen wollen nur von
Versprechungen und Ankündigungen kann
kein Metzger kann kein Busunternehmen
kann kein Bäcker kann kein Handwerker
seine Rechnungen bezahlen und deshalb
wenn Sie sich diesen Antrag mal
durchlesen sie sagen welche Vorschläge
haben Sie denn vielleicht hat man Ihnen
im Büro die falschen Unterlagen
vorgelegt ich kenne unseren Antrag wir
schlagen zum Beispiel vor dass die
Biomasse dass der Deck in der Biomasse
einfach mal wegkommt wenn es heißt
All-In warum haben Sie denn da einen
Deckel drauf und wenn sie
die Anbieter erweitern wollen vom Strom
die Angebotsseite erweitern wollen und
dass am Ende der Preis sinkt ja warum
setzen sie denn jetzt durch dass die
Atomkraftwerke die Kernkraftwerke lange
länger laufen damit kriegen wir es hin
steht im Antrag drin ich finde das
ziemlich konkret lieber Herr [ __ ] und
dann will ich auch mal mit zwei drei
Märchen hier auch aufräumen das ist ja
ihre ganze Leier die ganze Zeit da
halten sich ja fest wie wir an
irgendeinem Gerüst sie sprechen die
ganze Zeit davon wir hätten keine LNG
Terminals gebaut mir sind die Grünen
nicht aufgefallen in vergangenen zwei
Jahrzehnten dass sie die Kämpfer und
Demonstranten waren für lng-terminals im
Gegenteil im Gegenteil war es und dann
sage ich noch mal was zu Herrn gremmels
was sie meinten mit Bayern die Leier
klappt ja auch nicht mehr ganz laut
Bundeswirtschaftsministerium ist das
Bundesland mit den meisten erneuerbaren
Energien der Freistaat Bayern
Bundesland Nummer eins bei der Biomasse
Nummer eins bei der Photovoltaik Nummer
1 bei der Geothermie und wenn wir uns
bei der Windkraft sind wir vor dem
grünen Baden-Württemberg also
Bayern ein bisschen schwierig und
deshalb
die Situation die ist schlichtweg
dramatisch es sind explodierende
Energiepreise und es geht auch um die
Energieversorgung es geht ja nicht mehr
nur um den Preis sondern auch darum dass
jetzt mittlerweile Unternehmen gar
keinen Vertrag mehr angeboten bekommen
und natürlich sagt die Bundesnetzagentur
wir müssen um 20 Prozent unseren
Gasverbrauch senken die Industrie hat
das geschafft aber das ist nicht nur
Grund zur Freude denn ein Drittel fährt
daher rührt daher dass Unternehmen ihre
Produktion eingestellt haben und deshalb
kein Gas mehr brauchen das geht an die
Substanz das geht an die Lebenswerke das
geht an unser Wohlstand das geht an die
wirtschaftsfähigkeit dieses Landes und
die Wettbewerbsfrage wird ganz neu
gestellt aber dass sie in dieser Zeit
noch nicht mals zitherapifizieren
sondern diese Woche schon wieder von der
Tagesordnung nehmen das zeigt doch dass
sie die ganze Zeit nur am schwätzen sind
und nichts machen und davon kann kein
Unternehmen die mitarbeiterlöhne
bezahlen die Erzeugerpreise sind 46%
höher als ja und das ist der höchste
Wert seit Beginn der Statistik und dann
schaue ich mir noch mal die das nächste
Märchen an die cdu/csu hat uns in die
Abhängigkeit von Russland gebracht also
besondere sinnsubtilen für Humor haben
sie ja muss ich sagen
ein paar Namen nennen aus der
SPD-Fraktion die sind sehr sehr eng ich
weiß nicht ob sie Russisch sprechen aber
es Geld können sie annehmen da kann ich
Ihnen auch sehr deutsch sagen 2014
Anfrage an den damaligen
Bundeswirtschaftsminister Sigmar Gabriel
bei den Verkauf des erdgasspeichers an
den russischen Gazprom eines
Unternehmens da war die Antwort eine
Unterbrechung russischen Erdgas
russischer Erdgaslieferung hätte laut
Bundesregierung keine schädlichen Folgen
beziehungsweise sei unbedenklich also
wenn sie in die Geschichtsbücher gucken
dann gucken Sie mal genauer rein sie
waren beteiligt und deshalb damit möchte
ich schließen will ich sehr klar sagen
es geht darum dass wir die Angebotsseite
erweitern dass wir eine Basispreis für
Gas einführen und dass wir vor allen
Dingen die kalte Progression jetzt
rückwirkend auch vor allen Dingen
ausgleichen und den Unternehmen helfen
mit super abtreiben und mit besseren
denn am Ende geht es ums Überleben und
nicht uns diskutieren
jawohl
ich war jetzt sehr gängig nächster
Redner ist der Kollege Andreas
mildretter SPD-Fraktion
[Applaus]
sehr geehrter Herr Präsident sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren der britische
Guardian hat letzte Woche Goldman 6
zitiert der Gaspreis könnte sich bis zum
Ende des Winters wieder halbieren der
Grund die gemeinsamen europäischen
Anstrengungen sein erfolgreich sie
würden einen gasmangel im Winter
verhindern es ist sicher viel zu früh um
wirklich Entwarnung zu geben und es ist
uns völlig bewusst die BürgerInnen die
Bürger und die Unternehmen stehen vor
riesigen Herausforderungen bei denen sie
Unterstützung brauchen es ist aber auch
klar es ist die Arbeit unserer
Ampelkoalition die tatsächlich eine
ermutigende energiepolitische
Perspektive gibt
es ist die Ampelkoalition die dafür
gesorgt hat dass sie garspeicher fast
komplett gefüllt sind es ist die
Ampelkoalition die entlastungspakete von
mittlerweile 95 Milliarden Euro auf dem
Weg gebracht hat und es ist die Ampel
Koalition die den Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energien deutlich
beschleunigt hat
liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der
Union wer nur markige Sprüche ohne jede
Substanz von der Seiten aus Linie aufs
Spielfeld brüllt der muss sich schon
fragen lassen warum er eigentlich noch
ernst genommen werden sollte sie werfen
uns in dem Antrag eine verfehlte
Krisenpolitik vor während sie vieles
fordern was wir sowieso gerade schon
umsetzen verstehen sie das unter
ernsthafter Oppositionsarbeit sie nennen
uns Verhinderer verhindern aber
gleichzeitig immer noch mit Vorgaben
wieder 10h-regelungen Bayern den Ausbau
der Windenergie merken Sie eigentlich
dass das nicht so wirklich zusammenpasst
und sie sind nicht einmal sich zu schade
und sie in ihrem Antrag vorzuwerfen wir
würden bewusst Blackouts in Kauf nehmen
diesen verleumberischen Populismus
können Sie sparen Liebe Union
wie wollen Sie denn eigentlich die
erneuerbaren Energien ausbauen dazu
steht in dem Antrag nichts sie denken
immer noch ausschließlich Fossil das
wird hier wieder mal deutlich mit den
fossilen allein werden wir aber die
Krise nicht bewältigen gut dass sie
nicht mehr im Kanzleramt und im
Wirtschaftsministerium sitzen
meine Damen und Herren wie sieht denn
die Lage wirklich aus der letzte
Stresstest hat gezeigt dass wir durchaus
bei der Energieversorgung ein Problem
haben nämlich Länder mit schwarzen
Regierungsparteien im Süden Deutschlands
sie haben den Ausbau der Windkraft
verhindert sie haben den Ausbau der
Stromnetze verhindert und sie tun jetzt
ja immer noch so als wären
Kernkraftwerke mit Leckagen die Lösung
für alle Probleme obwohl sie selbst 2011
den Ausstieg als guten Gründen besiedelt
haben
meine Damen und Herren wir müssen die
Versorgung mit Strom und Gas
sicherstellen timo gremmels hat gerade
sehr deutlich gemacht was wir dafür
alles tun und warum wir damit so
erfolgreich sind dass sogar Friedrich
Merz branchenfreunde uns loben wir
wissen aber natürlich dass die
Energiepreise viele gerade vor
existenzielle Herausforderungen stellen
wir wissen dass wir noch nicht überall
die notwendige Unterstützung leisten
aber wir werden dafür sorgen dass
niemand von den Energiepreisen
überfordert ist wir werden niemanden
alleine lassen das gilt
ein reduzierter Preis für den
Grundbedarf an Strom der kommt ein
reduzierter Preis für den Grundbedarf an
Gas darum wird doch gerade mit Hochdruck
gearbeitet und die notwendige
Unterstützung für kleine und mittlere
Unternehmen die bringt es
Wirtschaftsministerium gerade auf den
Weg Herr Kollege erlauben sie eine
Zwischenfrage aus der afd-fraktion
meine Damen und Herren das alles was
hier die Union fordert haben wir schon
lange mit dem Entlastungspaket drei
beschlossen wir haben diese Wochen diese
Woche auch die ersten Gesetze zur
Umsetzung in den Bundestag eingebracht
wir haben eine wohngeldreform und das
neue Bürgergeld auf dem Weg gebracht wir
setzen unsere Zusagen jetzt Stück für
Stück um das ist seriöse Politik
ganz im Gegenteil zu dem unseriösen
Schauspiel das sie aufführen hier im
Bundestag lamentieren sie das alles
nicht schnell genug geht und
gleichzeitig verhindern sie mit ihren
Ministerpräsidenten im Bundesrat dass
das Entlastungspaket schnell umgesetzt
wird sie behindern Entlastungen anstatt
sie mit uns voranzutreiben so schauts
aus
Liebe Union vor das Sommerpause haben
sie gedroht vor dem
Bundesverfassungsgericht zu klagen wenn
wir wegen der Energiekrise die
Schuldenbremse noch einmal aussetzen
würden
gleichzeitig fordern Sie jetzt dutzende
Milliarden an weiteren Entlastungen in
diesem Antrag ohne ein Wort zur
Gegenfinanzierung vom eg-konto abgesehen
was gilt denn nun oder kann sein dass
sie einfach gerne Forderungen Aufstehen
die logisch gar nicht zusammen gehen
meine Damen und Herren wir stehen vor
einer extrem schwierigen Situation wir
müssen alles Erforderliche tun damit wir
gemeinsam gut durch die Krise kommen
vieles haben wir schon beschlossen und
umgesetzt einiges wird noch kommen
wir sorgen dafür um es auf den Punkt zu
bringen dass sie Lichter und die
Heizungen nicht ausgehen und das niemand
von den Rechnungen dafür überfordert
wird darauf können Sie sich verlassen
danke
vielen Dank Herr Kollege
der Kollege Dr malte Kaufmann
afd-fraktion
[Applaus]
herr Präsident meine sehr verehrten
Damen und Herren viele Bürger in
Deutschland machen sich zurzeit zu recht
große Sorgen wegen eines drohenden
Blackouts Millionen Menschen sind
entsetzt über die immer weiter
steigenden Preise für Strom Heizung
Benzin und Güter des täglichen Bedarfs
aber nicht nur die Bürger trifft es auch
die Wirtschaft leidet extrem unter den
hohen Preisen erste Traditionsfirmen
sind schon insolvent es wurde
angesprochen eine Pleitewelle droht
dahinter stecken Schicksale von
tausenden Unternehmerfamilien und
Hunderttausenden Angestellten die ihre
Arbeit verlieren werden
nicht selten zerrinnt derzeit das
unternehmerische Werk von Generationen
innerhalb kürzester Zeit zwischen den
Fingern
in einer derart krisenhaften Situationen
muss doch das Gebot der Stunde lauten
alle Register müssen gezogen werden alle
verfügbaren Energielieferanten müssen
genutzt werden damit diese dramatische
Preisspirale gestoppt wird
und deshalb ja die Windkraft die im
Moment verfügbar ist natürlich aber auch
was die CDU fordert die drei derzeit
noch in Betrieb befindlichen
Kernkraftwerke weiterlaufen zu lassen
das wäre das Gebot der Stunde meine
Damen und Herren
und als afd-fraktion geht das uns nicht
weit genug legen sie endlich ihre
ideologischen Scheuklappen ab und machen
Sie moderne Kerntechnologie in
Deutschland wieder grundsätzlich möglich
im
unionsantrag sind weitere Punkte
enthalten die wir schon lange fordern
zum einen die Absenkung von stromsteuern
und Netzentgelten und zum anderen auch
die Rücknahme der unsäglichen gasumlage
schaffen Sie die wieder ab
und Herr Minister Habeck sie haben am
Mittwoch Ehrlichkeit und
Verantwortungsbereitschaft eingefordert
dabei sind sie es damit seiner
verschleppungstaktik in Bezug auf die
Kernkraftwerke zutiefst
verantwortungslos agiert
[Applaus]
zumindest hat ihre Rede gezeigt dass
ihre Nerven ganz offensichtlich blank
liegen sie sind als Wirtschaftsminister
vollkommen überfordert wenn man nicht
wenn man in dieser Situation nicht mal
weiß was eine Insolvenz ist
sie ahnen wahrscheinlich dass das
drohende Desaster für Deutschland für
immer mit ihrem Namen und mit dem Namen
ihrer Partei verbunden sein wird den
Kollegen der FDP sei gesagt wenn Sie
sich dieses politische Schicksal
ersparen wollen beenden Sie das endlose
Chaos und schalten Sie nicht die
Kernkraftwerke ab sondern schalten Sie
diese unsägliche Ampel ab das wäre ein
großer Dienst für unser Land vielen
herzlichen Dank
vielen Dank Herr Kollege
[Applaus]
als nächste Rednerin hält das Wort die
Kollegin Sandra detzer mit nicht 90 die
Grünen
sehr verehrter Präsident meine Kollegen
und Kollegen der Hashtag danke Habeck
trendet diese Tage auf Twitter und es
ist auch völlig klar
[Applaus]
Krisen die stirnbiete statt sie nur
auszusitzen und das Ernsthaftigkeit und
Schnelligkeit ganz genau passt zu den
massiven Sorgen der Menschen und vieler
Betriebe in diesem Land und ja das tut
weh ich glaube nicht dass sie Industrie
tut Liebe Union ich nehme jetzt einfach
mal die Überschrift Ihres Antrags liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen von der Union
und ich dekliniere das mal durch Punkt
eins wir geben BürgerInnen eine
energiepolitische Perspektive wir
sichern akut die Gasversorgung vieler
hunderte Stadtwerke ab indem wir die
uniper stabilisieren und damit Millionen
Haushalte vor Kälte und Dunkelheit
bewahren wir bauen einen g-terminals
sind rekordgezeit und wir haben das
größte auswahlpaket für die Erneuerbaren
beschlossen damit durchbrechen wir
endlich den Fluch des gasfetisch mit dem
die Union dieses Land an den Rand der
Funktionsfähigkeit geführt hat
Punkt 2 wir bringen die Preise unter
Kontrolle
wir führen eine strompreisbremse ein die
die Kosten für Haushaltung KMU für den
basisverbrauch senkt wir bereiten die
gaspreisbremse vor damit mit einem fixen
Preis für den Grundbedarf und
Marktpreise für alles was darüber
hinausgeht und wir senken die
Umsatzsteuer auf Gas um ganz unmittelbar
Gaspreise zu senken und der dritte Punkt
auch wieder die Überschrift aus ihrem
Antrag wir verhindern insolvenzwellen
der Rettungsschirm für energieintensive
Unternehmen wird ausgeweitet auf alle
Branchen im Mittelstand im Handwerk
damit greifen wir rund einer Million
Betriebe unter die Arme die momentan
eben nicht wissen wie es weitergeht
jetzt fehlt da nur noch die Zusage des
Finanzministers der Vorschlag des bmwk
liegt auf dem Tisch und dann werden wir
den unverzüglich umsetzen
die Lage ist ernst meine Damen und
Herren und es ist gut dass es in diesem
Land endlich einen Wirtschaftsminister
gibt der dieser Aufgabe gewachsen ist
herzlichen Dank
Sandra der Zahn macht noch mal Werbung
für den
Bundeswirtschaftsminister Robert Habeck
jetzt ist wieder doch noch mal Schwung
gekommen in diese Debatte und ich
vermute mal das wird sich jetzt gleich
fortsetzen zumindest was die emotionale
Lage angeht argumentativ hören wir ja
hier in dieser Debatte nicht so
dramatisch viel Neues in den vergangenen
Minuten Thema in Kuban ist am Pult für
die Unionsfraktion und noch ist der ja
auch Vorsitzender der Jungen Union Frau
Kollegin detzer sie haben mal wieder
gezeigt dass die Twitter leider nicht
verstanden haben aber in dieser Woche
haben wir eh schon einiges erlebt der
dunnhäutige Minister Habeck hier mit
seinem hat in seiner Rede gefragt ob wir
hier im Fußballstadion sein
um es um ein Fußballspiel zu gewinnen
Herr Minister muss man nicht den
Gegenspieler anbrüllen oder wie sie dann
Kopfstöße verteilen sondern eine
Spielidee haben neue Spielzüge einüben
und gute Mitspieler haben und ich sage
Ihnen um Tore zu schießen da braucht man
einen anderen Weg ihre Politik der
gasumlage erinnert mich ehrlicherweise
ein bisschen mehr an Andi Möller Mailand
oder Madrid Hauptsache Italien es war
ein klassisches Eigentor
und die Zahlen
und die Zahlen der gasumlage sind ja
auch beeindruckend sie zahlen jetzt 8
Milliarden Euro an das finnische
Staatsunternehmen Forum zur Rettung von
Juniper das kann man hier in Deutschland
eigentlich kaum jemand erklären sie
belasten danach einseitig die Gaskunden
mit einer Umlage und ich frage mich
manches Mal wer will diese Umlage
eigentlich in diesem Haus wer will diese
Umlage eigentlich in Deutschland wenn
sie erklären vorher den Leuten Gas sei
die Brücke in die Zukunft sie sollen
ihre alte Ölheizung rausschmeißen und
belasten dann einseitig die Gaskunden
das ist keine solidarische Politik die
sie da machen
und wenn sie dann
und wenn sie dann sich hinstellen in
diesem Haus und lamentieren bei der
Windkraft ja es sei nicht alles
vorangegangen ich sage es Ihnen die
verbandsklagerechte und die
naturschutzvorgaben das waren keine
Erfindung der CDU am Ende sage ich Ihnen
auch jeder Rotmilan in diesem Land den
sie immer schützen wollten hat mehr
Windkraftanlagen verhindert als der
Bürgerprotest vor Ort es war ihre
Meinung die sie vorangetrieben haben
Frau Dr detzer auch in Baden-Württemberg
und wir und wir legen heute konkrete
Konzepte vor ein Dreiklang das Angebot
zu erhöhen die Preise zu senken und die
besonders hart Betroffenen in diesem
Land zu entlasten was Deutschland jetzt
braucht ist die Erhöhung eines Angebotes
und der Bundeskanzler hat gesagt man
muss alles tun um dieses Angebot zu
erhöhen aber wo ist es denn wo ist denn
die nationale Kraftanstrengung die sie
erklärt haben ob bei zu Atom bei Kohle
bei Biomasse bei neuen Gasquellen bei
Windkraft bei PV oder bei Geothermie sie
reden nur sie machen nicht das ist unser
Vorwurf es ist fehlanzeige
was Deutschland jetzt braucht ist eine
Preisbremse für den Strommarkt wir haben
das Thema Mehrwert order Prinzip und die
Frage Herr Kollege janitschek auch in
unserem Antrag angepriesen zu sagen es
braucht ein europäischen
Großhandelspreis fürs Gas deswegen der
europäische Bezug ist durchaus da wenn
Sie den Antrag gelesen hätten was sie
bisher machen um die Entspannung auf dem
Strommarkt zu sorgen ist bisher
Fehlanzeige was Deutschland jetzt
braucht ist ein industriestrompreis die
Arbeitsplätze bei den kleinen und
mittelständischen Unternehmen die sind
im wanken Millionen von Menschen fragen
sich ob sie im nächsten Jahr noch ihren
Job behalten die Franzosen und
Niederländer haben es bereits eingeführt
und wenn ich daran erinnern darf dann
war es der Bundeskanzler der im letzten
Jahr ein industriesturmpreis von vier
Cent hier versprochen hat der Industrie
ich frage mich wo ist dieser
industriestrompreis am Ende fehlanzeige
was Deutschland was Deutschland jetzt
braucht ist dass sie aufhören dass sie
aufhören die besonders hart Betroffenen
zu vergessen erst die Studenten und die
Rentner jetzt bei diesem Malz vor allem
die kleinen Einkommen sie entlasten die
Arbeit sehr entlasten haben die
wohngeld-empfänger und sie entlasten ab
35 40.000 Euro diejenigen diejenigen bei
der Abmilderung der kalten Progression
wen Sie vergessen haben sind die kleinen
Einkommen die kleinen Einkommen in
diesem Land diejenigen die jeden Tag
aufstehen zur Arbeit gehen und ihre
Kinder zur Kita bringt die wirklich
malochen dass das eine SPD in diesem
Land vergisst ist ein echter Skandal und
keine Fehlanzeige und deswegen folgen
Sie unserem Antrag wir geben 1000 Euro
für kleine Einkommen das ist der
richtige Weg danke schön
[Applaus]
vielen Dank herr Präsident liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen liebe Herr
kubanisch gratuliere zu einer tollen
Rede für Youtube es wäre schön wenn es
ein bisschen seriöser und mehr Fakten
orientiert gegangen wäre aber das können
sie gut teilen da freue ich mich für sie
ich würde gerne zu Ihrem Antrag
zurückkommen ich bin nämlich immer ganz
begeistert wenn die Union in Antrag hier
vorlegt war ich immer ganz gespannt bin
ob man da im Bausch und Bogen verwerfen
muss oder ob man auch Ansätze in der
konstruktiven
Oppositionsarbeit findet letzteres ist
selten aber es gibt richtige Punkte und
richtige Ansätze in diesem Antrag ich
werde gleich darauf eingehen ob die dann
immer realistisch gegenfinanziert sind
und ob sie das jetzt nur einfach nur
fordern obwohl wir schon auf den Weg
gebracht haben ist noch mal die nächste
Frage aber einiges aus diesem Antrag ist
durchaus zu gebrauchen wir haben ja
schon bei Grundsätzen das Problem wenn
Sie sich hier hinstellen na ja es geht
Schnelligkeit und Zielgenauigkeit und
wir brauchen jetzt sofort wirksame
Maßnahmen jetzt klingt super kann man so
sagen aber in der Praxis ist natürlich
die Frage wie macht man es und wenn man
zum Beispiel bei der Energiepreis
pauschale gesagt hätte wir klammern
Einkommen und ab einer gewissen Höhe aus
hätten wir viele viele Monate gebraucht
Einkommensteuererklärung und so weiter
und so weiter um das umzusetzen es
klingt super das Ziel genau zu machen
aber dann wäre das Geld in 18 Monaten
gekommen und nicht jetzt und
dementsprechend muss man sich manchmal
entscheiden
die Bundesregierung und die Koalition
handeln wir haben es schon mehrfach
gehört heute Kurzarbeitergeld und ich
werde in jeder rede hier sagen weil es
eins der Meisterstücke der Regierung war
der alten und der jetzigen ist es
Energiekosten dämpfungsgesetz und auch
Maßnahmen für kleinere und mittlere
Unternehmen wir kommen im Detail noch
drauf hier ist übrigens ganz besonders
wichtig dass wir Solo-Selbstständige
nicht vergessen die vergessen wir nicht
aber in der Ausgestaltung der Programme
und in der konkreten
antragsgelegenheiten muss das
entsprechend abgedeckt sein und ein
Thema was uns alle besonders umtreibt
zumindest diese Seite des Hauses sind
die Frage von Strom und gassperren es
ist gut und richtig dass die Regierung
vereinbart hat dass diese zu vermeiden
sind und wir erwarten darf ich ganz
ausdrücklich sagen von der
Bundesregierung hier auch ein
entsprechend schnelle Umsetzung weil
Menschen denen im wahrsten Sinne des
Wortes der Saft abgedreht wird sind die
aller ärmsten und da brauchen wir sehr
schnell Fortschritte
wie schon gesagt habe sind einige an
Punkte Ihres Antrags nicht verkehrt zwar
ich persönlich nie Fan der
gaspreisumlage ich glaube dass wir eine
sozial gerechte Ausgestaltung brauchen
und insbesondere seit der
Verstaatlichung von uniper eine andere
Ausgangslage haben ich bin froh dass
Robert Habeck eine schnelle juristische
Prüfung an gedrängt hat und
angestoßen hat und freue mich da und
gehe von schnellen Ergebnissen und
Reaktionen aus ebenso gehe ich davon aus
dass die Kommission zum Thema Gaspreis
ihrer Verantwortung gerecht wird und
schnell zu konkreten Lösungen kommt die
wir dann auch schnell umsetzen können es
muss dringend in diesem Jahr noch sein
ich bin hochbegeistert und das gemeine
ich gar nicht gar nicht schnippisch dass
sie in den gaspreisdeckel für den
Grundbedarf vorne das habe ich hier im
Juni schon mal gesagt da wurde von ihnen
noch herzlich gelacht und das irgendwie
als nette Forderung des DGB kommentiert
Ende Juli ist Herr Spahn dann drauf
aufgesprungen ich freue mich das ist
mittlerweile fordern ob sie es umsetzen
würden wenn sie selber regieren würden
darf man vielleicht noch mal
hinterfragen glaube aber dass das
richtig ist dass wir hier auf dem Weg zu
einem Konsens sind leider und das ist
das aber in der Frage bleiben sie die
Gegenfinanzierung halt schuldig und
dieses Muster setzt sich fort sie sagen
Netzentgelte für 2023 aussetzen die
Stromsteuer auf den eu-mindestsatz
Senken etc kann man alles machen aber
wie machen wir das denn ohne
Steuererhöhungen und neue Schulden
das alleine und das haben wir auch schon
mehrfach gehört in den letzten Tagen
Verzicht auf die gasumlage würde 34
Milliarden kosten die müssen irgendwo
herkommen und wenn ihren
Fraktionsvorsitzenden der nicht mehr da
ist heute auf N24 gesehen habe sieht man
auch dass es ihnen überhaupt nicht um
Lösungen geht da stellt sich Herr Merz
hin und sagt die Schuldenbremse ist
Gesetz das müssen wir machen im übrigen
wurden die Länder von dem
Entlastungspaket überrannt das heißt sie
suggerieren sogar dass das was wir
machen wo wir seit einer Stunde hören
das ist alles zu wenig doch irgendwie zu
viel und wir können uns nicht leisten
sie hören Sie mit diesem zündeln auf und
hören Sie auf Ihr so moralisch zu
agieren weil es wirklich nicht
glaubwürdig ist wenn man sich die
Details anschaut
und wir müssen die wirtschaftspolitische
Situation größer denken wir haben ein
angebotsschock auch das habe ich hier im
Juni gesagt da wurde auch noch groß
gejohlt auf der Seite das haben wir
verstanden und der hat jetzt auch zu
einem nachfrageschock geführt der GfK
des Konsumklimaindex denkt damit die
Nachfrage und damit ist klar dass wir
Anreize für die Konjunktur brauchen und
die Situation sich jetzt gravierend
verschärfen wird ich bin froh dass es
erste Maßnahmen zur Schaffung dieser
Nachfrage gibt und ebenso ist jetzt
unsere Hauptaufgabe den Kollaps des
Energiesystems zu verhindern es ist
wichtig dass wir die Energieversorgung
sicherstellen und bei Bedarf auch
kraftvoll zupacken uniper ist hier für
das beste Beispiel klar ist dass es nur
eine Übergangslösung sein kann aber auch
da hatten wir die Diskussion im Juni mit
Blick zum Beispiel auf die bayerische
Wasserkraft die die CSU 2003
verscherbelt hat weil man halt Geld für
den Bundeshaushalt gebracht hat wirklich
visionäre Energiepolitik sieht anders
aus und die Situation jetzt gibt auch
Chancen Fehler der Vergangenheit zu
korrigieren
kommunale Daseinsvorsorge ist bei der
Frage der Energiesicherheit niemals zu
vernachlässigen im Gegenteil ich glaube
sie kann gar nicht hoch genug bewertet
werden die Münchner Stadtwerke das darf
jetzt Abgeordnete aus München mal sagen
sind hier ein leuchtendes Beispiel wie
man es hinkriegt sich über viele Jahre
Visionär an Klimaschutz an
Klimaneutralität im kommunaler Hand zu
orientieren und wir sollten bei
Zukunftsfragen des Energiemarktes auch
mehr über Kommunalisierung und die
Stärkung der Daseinsvorsorge nachdenken
dass wir den Antrag trotz einiger guter
Punkte nicht mittragen können wird sie
nicht wahnsinnig überraschen vielen Dank
für die Aufmerksamkeit
Sebastian Roloff aus der SPD-Fraktion
hat jetzt gerade mal bewiesen dass wir
den Antrag der Unionsfraktion doch recht
gründlich gelesen hat und er sogar
einige Ruhe in die Reihen der Union
bekommen weil er nämlich den ein oder
anderen Punkt gar nicht so interessant
fand wir sind bei Andreas Lenz noch mal
Unionsfraktion dritt letzter Redner in
dieser Debatte Sprecher für Klimaschutz
und Energie
die Versorgung und gerade jetzt in einer
Zeit von
Energieknappheit müssen wir alles aber
auch wirklich alles machen um die
Angebotsseite bei der Energieversorgung
zu stärken wir müssen Potenziale bei den
Erneuerbaren heben aber eben auch bei
den konventionellen Kapazitäten die
entlasten damit die Energie und
insbesondere die Strompreise wir helfen
damit den Verbrauchern den Unternehmen
dem Handwerk und den Mittelstand und
diese Hilfe ist dringend notwendig und
es geht wirklich um jede Kilowattstunde
der Minister hat es ja mehrmals selbst
gesagt es ist eben auch eine stromkrise
das ist mittlerweile hoffentlich jedem
klar lassen Sie also die AKWs am Netz
hören Sie auf die Stellungnahmen im
Stresstest und der Verbände machen sie
alles um ernsthafte netzschwierigkeiten
im schlimmsten Fall einen Blackout zu
verhindern
[Applaus]
und sie tun ja häufig so als ob das
irgendeinen Mantra der Union sei sonst
würde das ja niemand fordern niemand
sagen hören sie auf den
Sachverständigenrat der Bundesregierung
das sagt das sprechen Sie mit Frau
Professor Grimm das sagt übrigens auch
ihr Koalitionspartner die FDP das sagt
auch das europäische Ausland sie sind
doch auch im energieministerrat das
sagen selbst grüne Abgeordnete im
Europaparlament beispielsweise der
schwedische Europaabgeordneter take
anstatt der Deutschland vorwirft keine
Verantwortung für die Energiesicherheit
zu übernehmen nehmen Sie diese Stimme
ernst wenn sie schon uns nicht glauben
lassen Sie die Kernkraftwerke befristet
am Netz überwinden Sie an dieser Stelle
ihrer Ideologie sie sparen damit weiter
Gas und entlasten den Markt und die
Preise es droht es droht die die
Industrialisierung Deutschlands und ich
rate jedem das entsprechend ernst zu
nehmen es war immer
es war immer das Produzieren der Gewerbe
das uns über Krisen der Vergangenheit
getragen hat das heißt die Finanzen und
Wirtschaftskrise oder auch andere Krisen
und übrigens wenn die Industrie aus
Deutschland verschwindet dann kann und
dann gibt es auch nichts mehr zu
transformieren hin zu einer
klimaneutralen Wirtschaft dann ist sie
einfach weg die Emissionen sind aber
nicht weg die Emissionen entstehen dann
an anderen Orten der Welt also schützen
sie den Mittelstand schützen Sie das
Handwerk durch Entlassungen an ein
höheres Angebot an Energie
ansonsten verspielen sie den Wohlstand
dieses Landes meine Damen und Herren
handeln Sie also es sind übrigens erst
zwei Kohlekraftwerke wieder ans Netz
gegangen die bezauber brauchen hier
Planungssicherheit nicht nur für diesen
Winter wir werden auch im übernächsten
Winter eine Energieknappheit haben und
außerdem stärken sie die Erneuerbaren
wir haben es da haben Sie unseren ihrer
Seite unsere Vorschläge liegen auf dem
Tisch beim Biogas decken wir haben heute
morgen bei der Anhörung noch weitere
Vorschläge die auch unseren Vorschlägen
entsprachen gehört setzen Sie diese um
die Vorschläge liegen auf dem Tisch
der Minister hat ja gestern gesagt dass
weitere Entlastungen notwendig sind und
kommen werden darauf hoffen wir aber
fangen Sie doch zunächst einmal damit an
dass sie nicht weiter belasten nehmen
Sie diese vermurkste gasumlage von vom
Tisch gerade jetzt wo uniper ja
verstaatlicht wird und wenn ich die
Diskussion mir vergegenwärtige gerade
auch die letzten Beiträge dann stelle
ich mir die Frage wer in diesem
Parlament ist denn eigentlich noch für
die gasumlage wir steht denn noch zu
diesem Konzept es ist aus meiner Sicht
immer noch so wie bei einer Jacke die
man falsch beginnt einzuknöpfen das wird
meistens nicht besser wenn man weiter
zuknöpft
entknöpfen Sie diese Jacke schaffen Sie
die gasumlage ab und nehmen Sie diesen
Vorschlag vom Tisch und entlasten bzw
belasten sie somit die Verbraucher nicht
noch mehr herzlichen Dank
vielen Dank Herr Kollege Andreas Lenz
war das
Sprecher für Klimaschutz und Energie aus
der CSU-Landesgruppe hat er gesprochen
und wir sind beim vorletzten Redner
Felix bannaschak Bündnis 90 die Grünen
und Kollegen Deutschland steht zweifels
ohne vor großen wirtschaftspolitischen
Herausforderungen die Energiepreise die
Energie Verfügbarkeit die Inflation die
drohende Rezession der Fachkräftemangel
der Fachkräftemangel betrifft das
Handwerk betrifft Teile der Industrie
und ganz offensichtlich betrifft der
Fachkräftemangel auch die cdu/cs zur
Bundestagsfraktion anders kann ich mir
anders kann ich mir nicht erklären mir
wäre das unangenehm mir wäre das
unangenehmen
der Wirtschaftsminister handelt wie ein
wirtschaftspolitischer Praktikant Frau
schlöttner sie haben gerade von einem
Schamanen gesprochen ich würde mich
schämen den Minister der gerade in
Karren aus dem Dreck zieht zu
beschimpfen und dann so eine dünne Suppe
zu servieren so eine dünne Suppe wie
dieser Antrag
zwei Seiten zwei Seiten voller
Widersprüche zwei Seiten voller
Widersprüche sie müssen sich schon
entscheiden sie waren ja 16 Jahre lang
eine staatstragende Regierung und haben
sich jetzt für eine klamau-opposition
entschieden die dieser epochalen
Herausforderung vor denen wir stehen
einfach nicht gerecht wird sie können
doch nicht ernsthaft
sie können doch nicht ernsthaft in einem
solchen Antrag schreiben wir wollen eine
gaspreisdeckel müssen wir nicht wie wir
es bezahlen wollen wir wollen keine
gasumlage keine gasumlage ohne irgendwie
zu diskutieren was denn die Alternative
wäre was ist ihre alternative wollen sie
wollen sie die Gasversorger pleite gehen
lassen wollen Sie dass die Stadtwerke
pleite gehen wollen Sie dass die
Energieversorgung ausfällt oder wollen
sie das Geld woanders lernen diese Frage
müssen sie beantworten aber das was sie
mit das was sie mit diesem Antrag und
was sie mit allen Reden in dieser Woche
gemacht haben ist immer nur nein keine
gasumlage keine neuen Steuern keine
neuen Schulden das ist ein
mathematisches Ding der Unmöglichkeit
und ich frage mich wie wenig ernst
nehmen kann man sich denn als Opposition
in einer soepochalen Krise
sie sprechen sie sprechen in diesem
Antrag von einer energiepolitischen
Perspektive für die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger und die Unternehmen diese
energiepolitische Perspektive ist
angesprochen worden geben wird wir bauen
das muss man noch mal anerkennen grüner
Wirtschaftsminister baut rein Weise
lng-terminals auch schaffen neue fossile
Fachschaft neue fossile Infrastrukturen
lässt Kohlekraftwerke länger laufen
bringt AKWs in einen Reservebetrieb um
kurzfristig zu agieren aber meine Damen
und Herren da draußen demonstrieren
heute wieder hier in Berlin und
deutschlandweit junge Menschen für ihre
Zukunft dafür dass wir ein lebenswerten
Planeten auch noch vorfinden wir
brauchen doch nicht nur eine
energiepolitische Perspektive für die
nächsten drei Wochen sondern auch eine
für die nächsten drei Jahrzehnte und das
bedeutet endlich alle Hürden alle würden
über Bord zu werfen die doch den Ausbau
der Erneuerbaren blockieren zehn Hallen
Bayern wir haben es in
Nordrhein-Westfalen geschafft mit ihnen
die Abkehr von 1500 Metern 1000 Meter
abstandsregelungsvereinbaren vielleicht
braucht eine grüne Regierungsbeteiligung
in Bayern damit das auch in zum Glück
jetzt vielen Dank
vielen Dank so felix banaschak war das
noch mal Fraktion Bündnis 90 die Grünen
und den Reigen schließt jetzt in dieser
Debatte in der so meinen Antrag in der
Unionsfraktion zur Energiepolitik geht
Olaf in der Weg klimapolitischer
Sprecher seiner Fraktion ja Herr
Präsident
t
was wir mal zusammen ist ja irgendwie
völlig unstrittig wir leben in
schwierigen Zeiten der Angriff kriegt
Putins und der daraus folgende
Wirtschafts- und ressourcenkrieg heißt
massive Auswirkungen in Europa und auch
in Deutschland damit habe ich schon
genauso viel mal Europa gesagt wie in
dem Antrag steht die Bundesregierung und
die Fraktion der Ampel arbeiten jeden
Tag mit Hochdruck daran die Probleme zu
lösen und die aktuellen
Herausforderungen zu meistern und genau
das was sie in ihrem Antrag fordern tun
wir Tag für Tag als Regierung und
Fraktion wir arbeiten
wir arbeiten daran Perspektiven zu geben
Preise unter Kontrolle zu bringen und
Insolvenzen zu verhindern aber eins das
wird uns nicht passieren wir werden
sicher nicht in Aktionismus verfallen
die Ampel arbeitet klar und strukturiert
lassen Sie mich
lassen Sie mich ein paar Sätze zu ihren
Ideen sagen liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen da unseren Fraktionen sie
wollen also die gasumlage abschaffen und
einen gaspreisdeckel sowie ein
bürgerbasispreis einfordern hört sich
alles toll an aber nur weil Kosten
gedeckelt werden die wohl Union musste
Differenz trotzdem irgendjemand Allrad
zahlen und glauben Sie dass das Geld vom
Himmel fällt ich bin gespannt auf Ihre
Vorschläge wie sie das mit der
Schuldenbremse in Einklang bringen ich
nehme es vorweg gar nicht vielleicht
sollte der Kollege Czaja einmal mit
seinem Bruder sprechen unserem
Fraktionsvorsitzenden Abgeordnetenhaus
vom Berlin der wird Ihnen das vielleicht
mal erklären wenn ich wie ihre Sammlung
wenn ich mir ihre Sammlung von Ideen
anschaue muss ich mich schon sehr
wundern was aus der Partei Ludwig
Erhards eigentlich geworden ist
fiskalpolitisch bewegen sie auf dem
Niveau der Linkspartei aber sei es drum
aber seis drum
vielen steht das Wasser bis zum Hals und
gerade im Hinblick auf die
Energiesicherheit und Bezahlbarkeit
handeln wir eine entscheidender Schritt
ist zum Beispiel der Umgang mit der
deutschen rostlab Töchtern so
gewährleistet unter andern durch die
untertreuernstellung der PCK Raffinerie
in Schwedt die Versorgungssicherheit in
Ostdeutschland als Liberaler ist mir
natürlich immer lieber wenn der Markt
wirken darf und sie staatliche Eingriffe
in Grenzen halten aber in der jetzigen
Situation müssen wir pragmatisch handeln
das ist auch unser Verständnis von der
Aufgabe des Staates wenn der Gas und
Strommarkt nicht mehr im Sinne der
Verbraucher funktioniert da muss der
Staat in Ausnahmefällen Eingreifen das
tun wir auch bei der Verstaatlichung
beispielsweise von uniper und ja der
Staat muss sich auch um den Mittelstand
um die vielen Betriebe in Deutschland
kümmern aber verunsichern sie doch nicht
die Menschen und erzählen Märchen dass
die Bundesregierung nicht zu unternehmen
würde wir wissen dass gerade die Preise
für Strom und Gas für viele
Schmerzgrenze liegen oder diese schon
deutlich überschritten haben deswegen
müssen wir nun alles dafür tun um die
Energiepreise schnellstmöglich zu senken
wir haben mit den drei
entlastungspaketen
entlastungspaketen bereits Maßnahmen
ergriffen und werden immer wieder
zielgerichtet nachsteuern ich bin
zuversichtlich dass das Ministerium in
Kürze Vorschläge für ein schnelle
Einführung der vereinbaren
strompreisbremse vorlegen wird die wir
hier in diesem Haus dann debattieren
werden und natürlich muss alles auf den
Strommarkt was wir zu bieten haben um
die Preise zu senken Kohle holen wir
schon zurück das tut mir als
klimapolitiker weh aber es ist notwendig
und können wir uns auch wirklich leisten
auch auf andere Energiequellen zu
verzichten wollen wir uns vorwerfen
lassen dass wir nicht alles dafür getan
haben den Menschen bei den absurd
steigenden Preisen zu helfen nein liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen das können wir
nicht deshalb werden wir auch weiter
verantwortungsvolle Entscheidung in der
Ampel treffen das gilt im Übrigen
sicherlich auch für die letzten
verbliebenen Kernkraftwerke das ist
unsere Verantwortung und daran dürfen
uns die Menschen auch messen dankeschön
vielen Dank Herr Kollege Olaf in der Weg
aus der FDP-Fraktion war der letzte
Redner in dieser Debatte die in großen
Teilen eher polemisch geführt wurde
statt von neuen Argumenten geprägt
gewesen zu sein das ist vielleicht kein
Wunder der Bundestag hat in dieser Woche
rund viermal über dieses Thema
diskutierter hätte man vielleicht auch
mal überlegen können ob man das
thematisch ein klein wenig bündelt also
wenig Neues in dieser Aussprache und
jetzt wird darüber beraten wie mit
diesem Antrag der Unionsfraktion
umgegangen wird da steht zu Diskussion
ob er abgestimmt wird hier direkt oder
ob er beispielsweise in den
Wirtschaftsausschuss überwiesen wird
dieses Verfahren wird jetzt hier gerade
besprochen und denn ich das richtig sehe
haben sich Union und AFD dafür
ausgesprochen den Antrag zu überweisen
und genau das ist jetzt passiert